BUT FIRST, BIDEN-ELEGY 101, THAT
IS TONIGHT’S ANGLE.
BACK IN THE COLD WAR, WE HAD
CRIMINOLOGIST, AND THEY SAID
EVERYTHING THEY COULD FIND,
PICTURES OF OFFICIAL NOTICES AND
SO FORTH TO GUESS ABOUT WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IN THE SOVIET UNION.
AFTER ALL, YOU HAD TO TRY TO
FIGURE THINGS OUT.
BUT THESE DAYS, I THINK WE NEED
BIDEN-OH IT JUST GIVEN 90% OF
THE TIME BIDEN AND HIS CAMPAIGN
ARE CLOSED OFF TO REAL QUESTIONS
OR SCRUTINY BUT EVERY ONCE IN A
WHILE, BIDEN EMERGES AND
IMMEDIATELY STARTS TO REVEAL HIS
REAL AGENDA.
>> SOMEONE SAID TRUMP’S STANCE
HAS A GOOD ONE TO COUNTER
CHINA’S INFLUENCE.
WOULD YOU KEEP THE TERRORISTS?
NO, HEY, LOOK.
WHO SAID TRUMPS IDEA IS A GOOD
ONE?
WE ARE GOING AFTER CHINA AND A
WRONG WAY.
>> Laura: WELCOME OF THE
ENTIRE 24-HOUR AT PERIOD THAT
FOLLOWED THAT EXCHANGE, HIS
CAMPAIGN AND THE MEDIA ALLIES
TRIED TO CLEAN IT ALL UP CLAIMIN
BIDEN DIDN’T REALLY MEAN WHAT
HE SAID ON TERRORISTS, GET RID
OF THEM.
A BIDEN AID TELLING BLOOMBERG
YESTERDAY HIS POSITION IS
UNCHANGED.
HE WOULD REEVALUATE THE TARIFF
UPON TAKING OFFICE.
HE WAS OBVIOUSLY RESPONDING TO
THE NOTION THAT TRUMPS STANCE IS
A GOOD ONE TO COUNTER CHINA.
NICE TRY, KIDS AS IF WE DIDN’T
HEAR THE WORD NO IN RESPONSE TO
THE QUESTION WHETHER HE WOULD
KEEP THE TARIFF SPIRIT NOW, THIS
IS WHERE BIDEN-ELEGY COMES IN.
STAY WITH ME HERE.
BIDEN’S TEAM ISSUED A STATEMENT
THAT WAS SUPPOSEDLY WRITTEN BY
THE FORMER VP HIMSELF.
AND WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT THE
STATEMENT WAS APPROVED AND
VETTED BY HIS ENTIRE ECONOMIC
TEAM AND IT INCLUDED THE
FOLLOWING KEY PASSAGE.
TRUMPS PHASE ONE TRADE DEAL WITH
CHINA IS FAILING BADLY, EVEN
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC, TRUMP GO IT
ALONE TRADE WAR WAS HAMMERING
AMERICAN WORKERS, SMALL
BUSINESSES, AND FARMERS.
WELL, WE BIDENOLOGY-ALL IT JUST
SENDS AN IMPORTANT SIGNAL TO THE
SWAMP.
IT MEANS THAT BIDEN WILL NOT USE
HIS AUTHORITY AS PRESIDENT TO
IMPOSE TARIFFS ON CHINA AND THAT
HE WILL LIST THE TARIFFS IMPOSED
BY PRESIDENT TRUMP.
FURTHERMORE, IT MEANS HE WILL
NOT TAKE ANY ACTIONS AGAINST
CHINA UNLESS THEY ARE SUPPORTED
BY SIGNIFICANT WALK OF OTHER
COUNTRIES, WHICH MEANS AS A
PRACTICAL MATTER, THE
EUROPEAN UNION, NOW YOU SEEK HIM
OTHERWISE, HE WOULD BE "GOING
ALONE."
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT HE IS
SAYING HE WON’T DO.
THE EUROPEANS ARE CUTTING DEALS
LEFT AND RIGHT WITH CHINA, AND
THEY WILL NEVER AGREE TO PLACE
TARIFFS ON THEM PERIOD.
THE OBAMA/BIDEN ANSWER TO CHINA,
BACK IN 2015 WAS THE NIGHTMARE
PPP, THE TRANS-PACIFIC
PARTNERSHIP AND BY THE WAY IT
WAS SO UNPOPULAR BACK HOME THAT
EVEN HILLARY CLINTON ONE OF THE
MOST COMMITTED GLOBALIST WHO
EVER LIVED SAID THAT THE TPP
WOULD KILL JOBS AND SHE RAN
AGAINST IT.
BUT BIDEN STILL BELIEVES IN THE
TPP ALTHOUGH MAYBE WITH A FEW
SAVE -- FACE-SAVING TWEETS.
>> I WOULD NOT JOIN THE TPP AS
IT WAS INITIALLY PUT FORWARD TO.
I WOULD INSIST THAT WE
RENEGOTIATE PIECES OF THAT WITH
PACIFIC NATIONS THAT WE HAD IN
SOUTH AMERICA AND NORTH AMERICA
SO THAT WE CAN BRING THEM
TOGETHER TO HOLD CHINA
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Laura: WHAT GIBBERISH.
HE CAN EVEN GET THE ACRONYM
RIGHT, TPP, JOE.
AND I WOULD NOT PAY ATTENTION TO
NEGOTIATION LANGUAGE.
THE OTHER TPP COUNTRIES, WHY
WOULD WE NEGOTIATE YOU AND OBAMA
AGREED TO?
AND THEY WOULD BE RIGHT.
YOU MIGHT SEE A FEW LITTLE
CHANGES HERE AND THERE TO HELP
BIDEN POLITICALLY, BUT THEN WE
WOULD BE RIGHT BACK TO A BIG
PUSH TO JOIN THE JOB KILLING
TPP.
>> FOR EIGHT, LONG YEARS UNDER
OBAMA/BIDEN ADMINISTRATION FROM
AMERICAN FACTORY WORKERS
RECEIVED NOTHING BUT BROKEN
PROMISES AND BRAZEN SELLOUTS AND
LOST JOBS.
AND OVER THE NEXT FOUR YEARS,
OUR PHARMACEUTICAL AND MEDICAL
SUPPLY CHAINS, WE WILL BRING
THEM HOME.
AND WE WILL NEVER RELY ON CHINA.
>> Laura: THE CHOICE COULD NOT
BE CLEARER.
YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT IN TRUMP
WHO SPENT REAL POLITICAL
CAPITAL.
HE CUT ON ENDING GRIEF IN ORDER
TO GET LEVERAGE OVER CHINA.
AND HE FORCED THEM TO CHANGE
THEIR WAYS OR BE CUT OUT OF THE
MARKET ALTOGETHER.
NOW BIDEN’S TEAM DECIDED TO
DESTROY ALL THAT LEVERAGE AND
RETURN TO THE FAILED OBAMA
APPROACH TO APPEASEMENT AND
TRADE POLICY.
NOW, THEY WILL TELL YOU THEY
INTEND TO RALLY THE WORLD
AGAINST CHINA, BUT THEIR OWN
RECORD SHOWS THEY HAVE NO CHANCE
OF ACCOMPLISHING THAT GOAL.
THIS LEAVES A HUGE WIN FOR THE
CCP AND A HUGE LOSS FOR AMERICAN
WORKERS ACROSS THE BOARD.
>> JOE BIDEN’S ENTIRE CAREER HAS
BEEN A GIFT TO THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY.
BIDEN PERSONALLY LED THE EFFORT
TO GIVE CHINA PERMANENT MOST
FAVORED NATION STATUS AS
VICE PRESIDENT, BIDEN WAS A
LEADING ADVOCATE OF THE PARIS
CLAIMANT ACCORD WHICH WAS
UNBELIEVABLY EXPENSIVE TO OUR
COUNTRY.
YET ONE MORE GIFT FROM BIDEN TO
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY.
>> Laura: IT IS A HUGE GIFT.
NOW IN SHORT, YOU HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT IT THIS WAY.
IF YOU WANT TO GO BACK TO THE
DAYS OF CHINA FIRST COME AMERICA
LAST, THEN BIDEN IS YOUR MAN.
IF YOU LIKE THE IDEA OF CHINA
UNCHECKED, RETURNING MORE
POWERFUL THAN EVER BEFORE, BIDEN
IS YOUR GUY.
IF YOU LIKE THE IDEA OF MORE
GOODS MADE IN THE USA, MORE JOBS
HERE IN AMERICA REFUSING TO
ALLOW THE COMMUNIST TO DOMINATE